خطوات سريعه ودقيقه فرضتها المعارك على
دروبها هؤلاء الجنود الاوكران منذ ان بدات
الحرب الروسيه قبل 10 اشهر ورغم اهميه
المساعدات العسكريه الغربيه والامريكيه
والدور الذي لعبته في تدعيم الجيش
الاوكراني الا انها لطالما اصطدمت بمعدلات
عده من ابرزها اللغه ليبدا البعض بمد
الجيش بسلاحها
لم يخطر
بها يوما الى جبهه القتال لكن الحرب التي
غيرت مسارت كثيرين في اوكرانيا دفعتها
للتطوع باعطاء حصص مكثفه باللغه
الانجليزيه لجنود اوكرانيا
بسيطه من جانبه من اجل بلدي واهله
والعسكريين الذين يقومون بحمايتنا من هذا
الهجوم الارهابي الروسي
اه خائف البروتينوشيوس حاجز اللغه ربما
يساعدها او لا على الاستغناء عن ترجمه
جوجل لقراءه الدليل الخاص ببعض الاسلحه
الذي عاده ما يكون باللغه الانجليزيه كما
قد يساعدهم على عدم اللجوء الى مقاطع
الفيديو على الانترنت للتمكن من استخدام
الاسلحه وفق تقارير غربيه تناولت شكوى
الجنود من عدم قدرتهم على استخدام وتشغيل
الاسلحه المتطوره
الانجليزيه التي تعلمتها تشبه ما هي في
الواقع زياره الرئيس الاوكرانيه الخاطفه
الى واشنطن التي تعهدت خلالها بالمزيد من
المساعدات العسكريه ابرزها نظام الدفاع
المضاد للصواريخ
ربما عزازات بدورها عند الجنود الاوكران
ضروره التسلخ بالانجليزيه لاستقبالها
وربما ليس ذلك فقط فتقارير اعلاميه غربيه
نقلت ان جنود الاسترشادو بالرئيس
الاوكراني الذي فاجعهم بتحسين اللغه
الانجليزيه التي مكنته من اداره لقاءات في
واشنطن من دون الحاجه الى مترجم يرافقه
حنان المصري العربيه